if you listen to this show you know we
occasionally throw music in and my
brother who works in radio it has a
couple of country music stations that he
looks okay overseas and he said you're
gonna like this song says it's Tucker
Beathard and I immediately said wait
Beathard family is this bobby Beathard
relationship said I think grandson
I say got a brother quarterback in Iowa
it goes yeah yeah yeah yeah they said
okay so the song is 2010 Tennessee I
come in and I'm singing it when I said
to seat man you're gonna love this song
put it on and then these guys start
roughing me up because it's about
Tennessee football Tennessee went in the
game and I said we got to have Tucker
bathra on so Tucker better just came in
from where were you Bermuda I was in
Nassau Bahamas yeah all right so he
comes in let me give a full introduction
No so Big Machine Records
Tucker beds new singles mama and Jesus
and that follows the top five summer
song they had rock on and 2010 Tennessee
is what I got kind of hooked on here
tour dates visit Tucker Beathard dot-com
now when you heard about this did
somebody tell you that we were talking
about 2010 Tennessee on the program yeah
I started getting blown up on like
Twitter and stuff like that I was like
what's going on man what'd I do
I saw you're all tagged in it and then I
was I don't know then people started
calling me and telling me gave me a
shout-out and oh wow okay now I want you
to play a little bit here now see no
Connor who's an amateur guitar player he
wrote real amateur because he thought
that maybe he was being a little unfair
to you with 2010 Tennessee but they were
making fun of me that I was fanboying
2010 GMC
so I said to Seton let me see if you can
write a song which seat wrote a song oh
man I did yeah I only write now I'm
pretty solid on the first verse and
chorus and I've got I've got another you
know verse and chorus going that I'm not
ready to play okay you judged him who
God you sure
yeah it's only fair absolutely okay so
your dad grandfather is Bobby it was a
great front office man built a couple of
dynasties they're great teams yeah all
right
your dad writes country music and then
your brother CJ quarterback in Iowa yep
it's a pretty pretty fun family to be
around I guess now you didn't write a
song about Iowa yeah I know it's a shoot
I mean I don't know I was growing up in
the SEC you know in the south it was the
Tennessee and Alabama of two teams that
really made sense for that idea of a
song you know but when it comes down to
it I'm a Hawks fan no no you are oh yeah
well I have to now CJ is also a musician
as well yeah we had a band growing up
and that played what was the name of the
band we called ourselves fade 49 because
they wouldn't let me name it mother
Tucker
[Music]
how about pick-6
that's a good one I'll shoot alright so
when you came up with the song 2010
Tennessee were you actually going
through a breakup
over is that one of those no I was
really just one that uh I was writing
with a guy and he he actually knows
nothing about football and just shout
out
tintin Tennessee and when I doesn't make
sense and I know we just wanted to try
to make write a song about a breakup and
somehow tie in a football game like that
I just think a little differently and
it's Tennessee actually beating Alabama
in this song yeah but that's the whole
point I believe that's the first time
that song is played Tucker and Dan
hasn't sung it Tennessee is always there
like they'd only make sense you know if
you hear the whole thing it's like okay
I get it you know there's you know
they're they're pulling away just like
you and your girlfriend or that kind of
yeah yeah I
it's got great hooks I'm glad you get it
how many tattoos do we have I got seven
ax7 yeah how did that go over at home
well me and my brother CJ at 18
got a matching one when my dad was out
of town and it's a Bible verse and the
problem was we didn't learn the verse
verbatim before he came home and called
us out on it and he looked at cj he said
you just didn't look cool what's that
what's it say then and then you're gonna
learn what I learned it but he did your
first now did you do something crazy for
your first one I tried I was too young
to get real tattoo so I wanted to brand
a cross on my chest I was like 15 wait
what were you gonna do we're gonna heat
up up the air it was like one of these
right here and I went into my brother's
room Oh with a loter and was like hey
dude that thing hurts and I woke up like
seven half how old are you 21 good for
you good for you yeah 19 year old Lamar
Jackson only won the Heisman that's you
and 21 I'm very blessed man and thank
you all for having me it's a now you may
change your mind in one minute as Seaton
O'Connor is gonna play his song it's
possible what is the title of your song
well that's the funny thing actually is
that Tucker your song was 2010 Tennessee
and I had written a similar song believe
it or not yeah yeah it's about a guy
that we work with here you might not get
some of these jokes but people on the
show I think will but you're saying yes
song 2010 Tennessee my song was 24/7
Purvi oh yeah I'm not sure if I get that
one yeah the guy in the back row sort of
a pervert he doesn't have a record label
he has no turd for dates
here's scene O'Connor with 24/7 pervy
the world premiere okay
wait oh man I guess that in do you want
you you want Tucker to play and you sing
she do that to you I don't yeah Aaron
the world premiere 24/7
damn it's me I'm just wondering where
Todd is I think I've known please don't
make me go get him you know where
they'll be
Nonna's town watching softcore TV play
again
only one just went down the door open
these clothes were lying in our
and I wish I couldn't see
but since I did I'll say only one scar
from surgery on scar one surgery
a trusted is that I've seen this Chinese
takeout all around never seen
but lying naked
on the ground and all the things I came
on scene when that fall turned around a
backwards head of smile
and Elway Jersey hospital game and as
you won't believe
New York City Fred sees 24/7 pervy I
don't bring you on tour with you Tucker
hey I got a Doug it was that your
country voice though that was well I had
trying to show my tucker no no but it
was just it was my first foray into
country music and I just I don't know it
just happened
good good thank you I was really I was
inspired and no joke as soon as we heard
2010 Tennessee and immediately what
popped in my head was 24/7 pervy go to
Tucker better calm he was on tour with
Dierks Bentley and big things from him
mom and Jesus is the new single but we
of course will always love 2010
Tennessee thanks for having me it's
great to have you let's have you back
all right I hope we promise not to do
what we just did
we'll come up with another song just
sing for it alright 20 after the hour
once again it's Tucker better calm are
you back on tour yeah taking taking a
little bit off for the for Christmas but
then going back out with Brantley
Gilbert starting up next year so good to
be touring a whole bunch and you know
keep on keeping on 21 years of age
Tucker better calm the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]